[Music]
hey guys before we begin we just wanted
to mention that JK news does have a
podcast so make sure to check out the
links in the description and don't
forget to read it in nope news nope
they're not checking out the podcast so
a divine love from Clemson where the
[ __ ] is Clemson I think that's a name I
think there might be your name from it's
a name name ma'am ma'am what's name
you couldn't person's own age we may
like the person's name
no Clemson is a university is it yes I
don't know holy [ __ ] I've never heard of
this university universities our
universities are white people about
right anything prestigious is my people
[ __ ] yeah you know that's we don't know
there's like Ivy League Ryan there's
like pac-12 schools and then there's
[ __ ] the Brigham Young's and Mormon
the warming diversity comes in there's
the ITT and deVry's and Mexican interest
for Asian people let's get real true
that's true a woman's mouth was
impregnated by squid semen after she ate
raw seafood what I know this video is
not gonna call that maybe woman ate
squid juice something like that
Jess you mean figured out she ain't like
she ain't like we needed my hands up
exactly she eggs and then she ate like a
male and a female and in the [ __ ]
sperm just like no yeah how does it so
she ate semen right from a squid putting
at a restaurant yeah did you think this
way was a guy did she faint pay for the
delicacy is what I want to know look is
that it is that part of it they don't
mention if she was at a restaurant or if
she was making it at home but all they
do mention is that she like she just
only half boiled the squid and then she
ate it and apparently this guy came in a
row
yeah it came in her mouth he got the
last laugh that's tight yeah so then
[ __ ]
and then his little legs shake I could
die now the best way to dies in a
woman's mouth please have daddy's like
nine I'm gonna get those that you need
to have eggs in her mouth for it to be
impregnated I think that's that's why
I'm a little confused too like why are
they using that specific term
impregnated but I guess it's because
they actually went into her mucosa like
it it's like Delta sperm just try to oh
that strong sperm because girls get came
din the mouth all the time of the time
yeah every day it's happening right now
so I always try to impregnate Jill's mom
you know it's my favorite thing to do
maybe maybe human sperm is just too big
to get through the [ __ ] dragon over
there brackets - is it for you hey my
bus permit use dude big Wow but then
squid sperm is microscopic so it comes
out like tadpoles yeah I think
impregnates a misuse of the word maybe
penetrated you call some wherever cuz
that made me really give a [ __ ] what
it's called what the [ __ ] happened like
let me figure this figure out the
adjectives first please let's hear this
[ __ ] yes apparently she was eating this
is there mana production meaning yeah oh
is it
Asia's went to college that's true
yeah so she ate some undercooked squid
the squid was a male or whatever it did
have its premises permit toads whatever
they're called I'm told Forbes Burma's
sperm sperm or no much Oh burn this is
[ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] room at Safari it's
[ __ ] calm things you think it's okay
just stay calm like your mother does
like her got her mother classy
come come come so anyway she put the
squid in her mouth and immediately she
felt some [ __ ] wiggling in her mouth
wiggling Jack it off so then she spits
it out immediately she doesn't owe the
[ __ ] I know just bidders are quitters
dude come on now come on man come on
just suck it up a little bit just for me
just a couple of times I could just
picture her husband in the corner like
just like with me just like with me same
thing my life story why you guys think
it's so personally like if it was so
much work for you guys me no cuz it
means that the girls and accept you for
who you are yeah for who we are you
accept yourself then do you follow your
own come if I could I would you can what
the [ __ ] if I could reach I would but I
can't no just you in your mouth yes the
day I make you eat it off my hand is the
day then maybe I'll have to eat it off
my hand to know I don't win dudes like
jerk off on plates and porn then the
girl eat it up almost like or they all
like into a shot glass yeah like a glass
I don't get why it bothers some men for
women to spit we're like why does it
have to swallow you don't accept the
mess is a straw right yes we want you to
take it from the straw sounds like the
truth right we don't want you to like
drop it off the floor and then we give
it to you so then you never want to see
the come shooting in to do you ever
thank you you know the scientific
demonstration I like you to see the
waterfall and a waterfall
yeah wouldn't the there's there's I
forgot the name of it but the girl lets
the guy bust in the mouth and then it
drips down like [ __ ] glaze on a
[ __ ] wiener but thanks
spitting right cuz she's not spitting
like hmm which can be hot too with that
she doesn't like it if she's like wait
[ __ ] minds
yeah can be hi no I'm not qualified yeah
I'll clean up if the girl already has a
track record of the fully accepting the
man and has swallowed maybe 2000 times
to know what she spits it up like she
doesn't want it I know that you actually
do want it and now it's hot
like she gets it in her mouth but she's
like the thumbs up doesn't for me yeah
was great I got there does she goes hey
no it's like if I come in Nikki's mouth
and then she quickly grabs her phone and
she Yelp reviews me five stars and then
she spits it out like I'm cool with that
yeah yeah the apps loading Mickey's
mother forever so immediately she went
to by the way she's 53 years old if you
guys are curious from South Korea Oh Oh
yuck octopus cuz then it's going on
young squid sorry yeah well I know squid
[ __ ] shot come out like that cuz I
don't even know where the squid dick is
like a guy who watches a lot of squid
porn I've never even thought about where
the squids dick is well yeah cuz they do
mention that she didn't prepare the
squid properly because she didn't remove
the genital organs yeah you're supposed
to take everything else do you know that
so when you have a squid like all the
organs are in that cap cap area oh so
you have to cut it open cut it out and
then separate it from the tentacles and
then you could there's a little thick is
in his head I guess I put the sperm
everything like the ink all that stuff
it did its head if you want to call it
it's just head tentacle so there's no
like torso or top head part either it's
just a cap and then there's the tentacle
yeah when you pull out a squid there's a
piece of plastic thing inside yeah
that's like it's like a it's like a coat
like a clear plastic thing it's weird
yeah I think it's Kella it's like the
only bone in their body
like one bone but it feels plastic yes
so she is up going to the doctor and
they found 12 small white spindle shaped
bug like sperm bags embedded in her
tongue and gums so see the chart here
those are sperm bags how does that
happen are you giving a squid a [ __ ]
I think like the question is so like in
the way it reproduces or the way when it
shoots out of sperm it's like it has
like hooks or some [ __ ] in it oh really
is that what it is no I'm just wondering
is there a picture that no there's no
photos somebody [ __ ] showed me a
squid cub the squid dummy bags and do
her Tom dude yeah like what the [ __ ]
it's like tide pod come she can't be the
idiot that this happened to but that's
really alien yeah I mean that's very
sci-fi alien type of [ __ ] I don't think
I would have just put a squid on the
grill like like for like that yeah I
boil it I want to clean that
[ __ ]
I googled squid common just a whole
bunch of Japanese porn oh yes good stuff
send me that some good stuff okay of
jokes claims this is disgusting yeah
yeah you know they've been doing that
since the ancient times there's like
woodblock paintings a [ __ ] tentacle
porn from like finding 14 something or
15 something have you seen the hentai
tentacle stuff what do they do with it
it's pretty nice man you didn't tell me
anything
wrap the girl right a finger bangers
they like playing all over holes with
tentacles man it's [ __ ] chemicals are
like soft there was a documentary on a
necklace I was talking about this this
type of genre and so I guess there was
like a famous Japanese artist like poke
side yeah the guy that did the wave but
so like I guess like I don't know if he
invented it but he has some tentacle
porn - yeah it's crazy that's like a
Jeopardy question he invented hentai
tentacle court easily who is hook side
yeah
but basically like I guess within like
drawing porn they still have to blur it
out if it's like peeing out to vaginal
insertion but if it's done with like an
animal or an animal object it doesn't
have to be blurred out also they did it
so that's why they did like tentacle
porn and all those other [ __ ] so he's
the one that created this this anime
artist created that genre loopholes yeah
so he found a loophole legal loophole
I don't know I forgot what the
documentary was but it was like on there
so that's why they do that because they
could show penetration exactly that's
why I was like cuz I saw this one anime
where a [ __ ] beetle was [ __ ] dis
fairy and I was like how come they don't
blur this [ __ ] out this is crazy
excellent film by the way
Benny this fairy this fairy girl was
[ __ ] a rat and I was like what the
[ __ ] is going on but the stories are
good it was a euphemism yeah they is
coach zodiac [ __ ] they're like these
fat [ __ ] the rabbit and the dragon
foxes no there's these fairies that
dress like bondage style and then they
fly around the forest and then they cure
everything by [ __ ] all the plants and
animals I don't know it was like a it
was like a manga things that you could
see it online and you could read the
stories that's probably a bunch of that
[ __ ] yeah it was really good I think
that's what Captain Planet was going for
they didn't quite get there now Captain
Planet was the first gay superhero dude
oh absolutely yeah was he out uh I'm not
sure I think he was as out as it gives
me a little bit I don't know who was
there though Captain Planet or the guy
who yelled Hart it's like dude the guys
like fire and it's like oh Jesus you
cracked me up there's an episode where a
guy was caught in a pit viper and he
just goes hard she can't help him out
the hole so he goes just wait for me
[Music]